the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
I'd like to in this evening lecture what
I'd like to do is continue a bit to
expand on and complicate and maybe also
deepen this idea I've been suggesting to
you that I'm labeling the Fred OTT
principle really a shorthand way of
describing the immensely complex scent
from an intellectual standpoint the
historical standpoint immensely of
exciting and astonishing process whereby
film went in a minute in an incredibly
short time from being a mere novelty to
being an embedded social formation in
the United States and and in other
industrialized societies and not just
only as embedded social formation
becoming by the end of the 1920s one of
the central media for the expression of
art and an artistic medium so that it
went from being a mere novelty from Fred
OTT sneeze in 20 years or so 25 years to
being a medium of astonishingly rich and
complex narrative art that progress is
part of what I mean by the Fred OTT
principle and and it might be helpful if
Ike if I concretize that a little bit
more by mentioning a bit more about what
I mean about the what I was implying or
referring to when I spoke about that
moment of imitation remember I said that
there were essentially through that the
that the that silent film and
incidentally I take it as a model for
the way in which most new media systems
develop in culture you can apply this
same basic schema to other forms of
popular entertainment including shocking
as it may seem
Shakespeare's public theater and I'll
come back to the implications of that
analogy the idea that Shakespeare was
the movie of his time that Shakespeare's
theatre was the Hollywood studio system
of it
of the of the Elizabethan era is a very
complicated one it's a very inspiring
one and it's it's complicated because it
makes us reassess our inherited notions
about what art is and where art comes
from one of the subtexts in this course
is precisely that the it has to do with
what I call the enabling conditions of
art and I'll come back to that again as
a theme again and again in in the course
so part of what I mean by the Fred OTT
principle is this is this roiling
complex partly unpredictable process
whereby a popular and an enlarging
population incredibly hungry for the
novelties being produced by this new
technology create a kind of symbiotic
relationship between the audience and
the emerging medium so that as the
medium be the medium grows more
complicated in part because the audience
ok after 5 or 10 or 15 visits to the to
the Nickelodeon or or to the the first
after the movies moved out of after the
movies moved out of the penny arcade's
and began to take their own space as
some of you know and as as is recounted
in our reading for this for these early
weeks the movies first moved out into
what we're called Nickelodeon's right
they were they were storefronts in them
for the most part in which you admission
was a nickel that's why they were called
Nickelodeon's and you sat in many of
these on benches without backs next to
strangers you didn't have private seats
and you would sit in there and see a
series of short films so but the fact
that the Nickelodeon's emerged so
quickly is a mark of how popular and the
film became even even in the even in its
relatively primitive early form and and
then of course within a few years of the
Nickelodeon's appearing what else began
to happen theaters made specially for
the showing of motion pictures that were
longer than the early shorts because
film began to expand its length all
through the period from 1910 through
1920 right what what's the great moment
when the feature film is born in the
United States 1915 who's the director DW
Griffith who's what's the film Birth of
a Nation birth of an
a very complicated example because it's
content is disturbing in some ways it's
a very reactionary and in some respects
racist film it it it absorbs and carries
forward what we might think of as the
the racial prejudices that were very
widespread in American society at the
turn of the century and especially in
the south from which Griffith himself
was but was a southerner and was born in
the south and what his film was deeply
influenced by a best-selling novel
called the Klansmen which was a
celebration of the Ku Klux Klan and the
Birth of a Nation was so the content of
Birth of a Nation is very unsettling and
disturbing and even when it was first
released to the public to great acclaim
because it expanded the possibilities of
movies in all kinds of ways from a
technical standpoint it is an
astonishingly important film and from a
Content standpoint it's a very
disturbing film it's a wonderful
reminder of the fact that this progress
I'm describing to you is not an
unalloyed triumphal story even as the
movies became more technically
complicated and and more demanding and
longer and more interested in character
they also nonetheless carried the lies
and prejudices and and hierarchic
assumptions that were embedded in the
society from which they arose how could
it be otherwise every media forum does
this but it's but it's important to make
this point as a way of reminding us that
the story we're telling is not in some
simple sense just a kind of a kind of
progress myth in which we're celebrating
development and and and genius where
where I identify and locating something
more complicated that the process
whereby these cultural myths and the
stories that are drawn from inherited
older stories and from and from the lore
of the society more broadly more
generally are are transformed into this
new medium and they have a tremendous
technical interest but very often they
also have a kind of cultural or
sociological interest of a negative kind
in the sense that what they reveal are
the prejudices the lies the limitations
of the society that's given
the mythologies that sustain the society
again this is a matter to which we'll
return one of the deep cultural
functions of American movies especially
was to promulgate a kind of Mythology of
America and we'll talk more about this
when we when we when we reach certain
genre forms in the second segment of the
course I said something earlier this
morning that I want to make explicit and
uh because I think it's an important
another way of qualifying this triumphal
story it's hard because I'm enthusiastic
about what I'm looking at and there is
some material that's so exciting here to
watch in a way what we're watching is
we're watching the birth of the movies
we're watching the the the discovery of
the language of cinema in these early
films and that's why even though from an
artistic standpoint some of these shorts
are not very rich I hope they're
interesting enough that I've made them
interesting to you from a historical
standpoint if you look at them closely
you can see there you can see the movies
being born you can see a language a
syntax for speaking in pictures for for
this new visual language be this new
visual medium being developed and and if
I have time this evening I'll give you a
few more concrete examples of that but
another way in which one can qualify
this apparently triumphal story it's not
a triumphal story even though it is a
story of refinement development and
evolution of a kind that involves
increasing complexity and technical
perfection technical mastery it's not
merely that or not or not or not even
primarily that it's very important to
recognize among other things as I
implied this afternoon that not all the
possibilities that are inherent in them
in the in the nascent medium aren't
necessarily exploited in a particular
cultural moment or or maybe ever
exploited depending on how things
develop that is to say I mentioned this
afternoon how for instance when Edison
first conceived the apparatus before it
was actually invented of the mode of the
motion picture projector and the motion
picture camera his first idea was that
he would create an item that would be a
consumer right what we would today call
a consumer item that would be sold to
into the
your families and the film would become
you know the the an equivalent of a kind
of a photo album although we would have
motion in it and and the and as I
suggested this this morning this
afternoon there's no reason why given
the nature of the technology itself that
that vision of how film might develop
was impossible in fact it wasn't
impossible it was just incredibly ahead
of its time it took it took a half a
century before something like that
actually became available in society but
there was no reason in terms of the in
the possibilities of the technology that
that that that needed to happen what I'm
calling your attention to is what is a
very widespread myth it's especially
pernicious and widespread at MIT and
it's ver for reasons that are obvious
and understandable we at MIT love to
believe that technology will solve all
problems
the primary thing I'm suggesting to you
is that the evolution of the movies that
I want you to be aware of this process
of increasing complexity and and
compression in which in which the movies
become a more and more independent form
of expression in which the movies begin
to discover the unique characteristics
of the motion picture camera and of the
environment of the movie theater that
the movie that the movies begin to
explore those qualities in this new
medium that are unique and special that
process is important and I want you to
be aware of it but I don't want you to
embrace that principle to uncritically
because I want you to recognize that
what that that the technology itself
does not explain this process the
process is explained by cultural factors
and social factors and even individuals
sometimes individuals psychological
factors right what we're talking about
here is the myth of technological
determinism the myth that technology
drives culture the myth that a new
invention obliterates old inventions the
truth is much more complicated than that
one of the most remarkable things about
this evolutionary process I've been
describing as I said earlier is how
Swift it is how fast it is how we go
from being a mere novelty to becoming a
significant social form by 1910 or so
and to becoming an a virtually Universal
aesthetic and entertainment experience
for the majority of the population in
the country
by 1920 so in something like 20 or 25
years the movies go from being an
absolutely unknown or trivial novelty
sharing space with fortune tellers and
strip and stand and strip shows in the
penny arcade's
to becoming not just an embedded social
form but one of the dominant economic
engines of the society employing tens of
thousands of people in various direct
and ancillary positions and mobilizing
virtually the entire population of the
country in an annex in a regular routine
and habitual experience to which they
return again and again and because the
audience is returning again and again I
remember I said there's a kind of
symbiotic relation between the audience
and then because the audience is
returning again and again what happens
that's also an aspect of the resources
that are available to the medium what
begins then to develop our form our
forms of storytelling that rely on the
audience's prior memory of other shows
right so that one thing that emerges
very quickly is what we might call a
star system in which particular actors
are become identified with particular
kinds of roles and audiences want to
come back to see those stars again and
again one also begins to happen is the
establishment of a very rigorous kind of
genre system what's a genre a category
of story the Western is a genre the
detective story is a genre the elegy is
a poetic genre right so genres so and
and and the movies are the the typical
the fundamental movie genres begin to
emerge relatively early there's a
western adventure story there's a
historical spectacle there are certain
forms of urban crime narrative that that
became our detective and crime films at
a later at a later stage and they're
certain and there emerge especially
certain forms of satire and comedy so so
as yawn resistant begins to emerge as
well and there are there are reasons of
course why this kind of thing is useful
to a mass production system to a system
an assembly line system because look if
you make seven westerns if the same
movie studio makes seven westerns they
can use the same horses again and again
they can use the same set they can use
the same hats
they might even be you and this in fact
happened they might even be be able to
use the same clip a film that shows a
cattle stampede in seven different
movies because nobody would actually see
it so economies of scale become possible
well as the system begins to regularize
itself once it stabilizes after that
period of imitation and patent warfare
right so one of the things that this and
there's nothing Noble or artistic or or
or conscious about this development
that's part of what makes it so
remarkable and it puts us in touch with
the paradox that's at the very heart of
what I hope to make you aware of in this
course it's a paradox that I guess it
animates my transition many years ago
now from a traditional literary scholar
into someone interested in film and
media and it's this paradox that based
on what I've been telling you about this
evolution this evolution of the medium
of the film medium it's the paradox that
capitalist greed the crassest of
alliances between Commerce and modern
technology might be the enabling
conditions of a complex narrative art
where does art come from it's about the
and it's not just about art though even
about sort of social even if even if we
forget the question of art and just talk
about sort of the the social and
cultural importance of movie-going in
modern societies leave out the question
of whether it's an aesthetically
valuable experience it's so central to
human experience remain so central to
human experience that there's a
tremendous power that there's a
tremendous paradox in this that the
crassest of alliances between Commerce
and Technology right nothing Noble or
admirable about it nobody's sitting down
thinking I want to make a new great
medium for art nonetheless
because these this alliance becomes the
enabling conditions for a complex form
of social experience and of narrative
art well that paradox is at the heart of
a lot of what we will be looking at in
this course I hope you'll keep it in
mind as we go on I'd like to say a
couple of words not too many a couple of
words about the Great Train Robbery the
very first film that you've seen this
the Great Train Robbery has discussed in
some helpful detail in David cooks
history
Neri to film and i urge you to look
closely at his account of it but i want
to remind you of about a couple of
highlights one is that that although the
Great Train Robbery seems very primitive
to us it's important to realize that
even the Great Train Robbery is already
a refined text almost most most of the
most fundamental principles of what we
might call the syntax or grammar of the
movies is already embedded in the Great
Train Robbery and what that means is
that the period the five or six year
period before that when there is all
this practicing with non narrative forms
lies behind the Great Train Robbery and
some and what also lies behind the Great
Train Robbery is this experience of
audiences going in to the first of the
penny arcade's then to the Nickelodeon's
that begin to open up in the in the by
the turn of the 20th century and
becoming impatient with repeated scenes
that simply show jokes hoses going off
in people's faces or trains coming into
a say after a while the novelty wears
off the audience wants but of course the
people who are making films are also
interested in what they're doing
you can feel especially if you look at
DW Griffith's shorts and you've looked
at you too you will have looked at two
of them in this course a beast at bay
from last time and the lonedale operator
which you'll see tonight before we turn
to the key films and you'll see and
these are just a sampling of his of his
early work but if you look closely at
those where you can feel Griffiths own
excitement at discovering the
possibilities of the cinema learn and in
many cases these W Griffith is doing
what doing some things with the camera
doing some things with narrative shapes
with the shaping of narrative in in
cinema that had never been done before
and you can feel his own excitement at
the possibilities of this of this
astonishing of this astonishing
technology well the Great Train Robbery
the most important discovery that the
Great Train Robbery shows us and again
it seems so obvious and so embedded that
we wouldn't even think about it today
we've absorbed these principles so
deeply into our DNA that we don't even
think of where we're we learn how to
watch movies in this way from the great
from the cradle in some ways because we
were but by the time most most people
today are five or six years old they've
been subjected probably to more
audio-visual images than
alive in 1900 and that's you know we're
just cognitively different from from the
in terms of our capacity to process
audio-visual information we and but
imagine an audience that's completely
illiterate in these things that has to
learn this system as the system itself
is evolving that's part of the
excitement of looking at these at these
early films and the most important
discovery in the great in the Great
Train Robbery is the discovery that the
shot the single the single uncut shot of
film however long it lasts and its
length that is dependent on on the
decision you make about when to edit it
right so it can it can go on for a long
time or it can be very short and the
length or the shortness of of cuts also
affects sort of the rhythm of your
experience and the film this is
something that you can see Griffith
practicing with even as as as early as a
beast at bay if you think about the
great climax of the beast that they
where you have the where you have the
the woman the woman being threatened but
you also have this sort of this sort of
race in the automobile to try to to try
to get there on time and then and then
the race to rescue her
by a variety of people but what Griffith
does is he cuts back and forth he
creates the principle of parallel action
what he realized what he discovered was
that the audience will recognize this
kind of cutting as showing you
simultaneity showing you things that are
going on at the same time it was what he
what he discovered were in a certain
sense how the mind how how we would
cognitively process certain kinds of
gestures on film and what he discovered
of course is that if he cuts if he edits
more quickly if he creates a fast rhythm
he creates excitement and if he create
and what he began to discover was
something that in later directors like
Hitchcock would carry to and to an
almost evil pitch a capacity to
manipulate and control the audience's
reaction by the speed with which
particular images appear or disappear so
so Griffith even at this early stage you
can see Griffith discovering important
principles the most fundamental
principle in a Great Train Robbery which
is not a Griffith film and the precedes
Griffith is the discovery that the shot
is the basic unit of action why is that
a great discovery
well if you
think of the if you think of the movies
as as a as a device or as a as a as a
medium that grows out of especially a
theatrical dispensation grows out of
other things as well novels feed into it
visual art feeds into the movies but
it's certainly true that most of the
major sort of ways in which directors
first conceived how to think about the
experience of what's of what the camera
is looking at they would they would have
been influenced by their own experience
of theatre and if you think about it for
a moment what you can see even in the
Great Train Robbery and and the an
impulse to treat the camera as a stable
thing the camera doesn't move very
camera but there are panning shots in
which the camera will go like this right
but the camera will not track it will
not move back and forth or sideways off
it's off it's in in the Great Train
Robbery it's that's a discovery that's a
discovery that Griffith is going to make
and will exploit and you can see it in
in a beast at bay but in the Great Train
Robbery we haven't got that for you but
what we have discovered what what Porter
Edwin Porter did discover was that the
shot is the basic unit of action and
then and what this means is it's not
simply what the camera sees but then how
the shots are edited afterwards that is
so crucial so what did what it came to
understand was that the making of them
of any movie is always a two-stage
process there's the shooting of the film
and then there's the editing of the film
right and that that itself is a
fundamental described but the idea that
the shot is the unit of action instead
of the scene was hard for movie makers
to get because and what they would do
they would set the camera up and then
actors would walk in front of the camera
they would do what they had to do and
they would walk off what's going on
there they're conceiving of cinematic
space in theatrical terms as soon as the
camera is liberated taken off its tripod
moved around in some way allowed to back
up work or come close even allowed to
move laterally or what we're beginning
to do was to explore more systematically
what the cameras unique features are how
the theater is different from the movies
how certain effects are possible in the
movies that would not be possible in the
theater when you watch the Keaton films
that you're going to see tonight watch
for the ways in which Keaton repeatedly
sets up situations so that
such that when you see a particular gag
of his a joke what you realize is that
the joke could not have happened in the
theater it could not have been told to
you verbally the joke is visual the joke
involves motion the joking the joke
involves a recognition of the powers of
the sin of the powers of cinematic
representation to tell stories and then
you'll see many examples of this in the
in the in the Keaton materials that
you'll that you'll be looking at tonight
so though so the one of the very first
discoveries that's made is the discovery
that the shot is the basic unit of
action a second discovery is the
recognition that you have to cut between
scenes you do your editing between shots
rather rather than the moat and what
mostly what you do is you let scenes
play out even though you might abruptly
cut a scene before the action is
completed one of that's another
discovery that was made if you cut the
scene if a person starts to walk toward
the door the first earliest films they
would show the person walking all the
way to the end walking out of the door
then filmmakers discovered wait a minute
there's a way of creating a kind of
quickness here because if I show four
burn walking toward the door starting
and I cut look and he knocks his glasses
off and then I and then I caught and I
wait till he gets to the door we see him
leaving the door I don't have to watch
him take those 17 steps that right so
what what what's been discovered is a
basic principle of cinematic syntax
right you know but what but but it seems
so obvious to us but of course it's
really a great discovery it's a you know
it's the the properties of the medium
have to be understood before you can
really begin to exploit it and that's
why I've asked you to look at some of
these short films none of the short
films I've shown you are completely
without some technical interest and even
though of course they're the only films
I'm showing you that I wouldn't sort of
make arguments to defend them as works
of art but I certainly would make
arguments for them as technically
fascinating documents and I hope you'll
I hope you'll look at them in in that
light so the shot as a basic unit of
action cutting between scenes with a
couple of other things in that in the
that I think are important in the great
train rock one is that you can see in
the Great Train Robbery they're
beginning to discover the value of
camera placement what happens when you
place the camera
position that if the camera especially
if action is coming toward the camera if
you that you might not want to place the
camera directly in front of the action
that's coming toward you that something
happens if you place it slightly afford
it so it can see it at a slight angle it
creates a greater illusion of depth in
the image for example and it does other
kinds of things it lets the action get
closer to you before before the scene
has to be cut so camera placement is
something that you can see is is
beginning to be learned beginning to be
mastered in the great trip in the Great
Train Robbery and fine art or camera
position so there are other things and
finally one might mention one other
thing that again
what establishes a principle that begins
that then is continued continues in
useful 50 or 75 years and that's the
principle of the process shot
you can see in the Great Train Robbery
that he couldn't that some effects have
been created by tricks that there's a
but there's back projection going used
in that if it looks crude to us we can
see through it but the early audiences
would would not have recognized that and
we we're so used to location filming
that we can pick out we today can see
through the process shots of earlier
films and this in fact damages some of
Hitchcock's films very badly today
because Hitchcock used a lot of
processed shot effects in his films when
he made them the audiences were used to
there was a convention of film going
today everything because cameras are so
much more mobile and light and so much
has been learned about how to even about
filming in low light and so forth that
they that there's much less use of
processed shot so that well then a new
kind of processed shot I suppose is
emerging with digital animation and one
could say it's sort of a return to the
idea of manipulating the image in
illegitimate ways but the but but we can
see even in the Great Train Robbery we
can even see the beginnings of the use
of processed shots of recognizing that
you can create effects in the movies
that are unique and special that no
other medium would allow you to do and
what's embedded there is science fiction
what's embedded there are all the kinds
of imaginative not just science
fictional all the kinds of imaginative
movies that have been made that maybe
take you inside people's nightmares or
dreams where what the film is showing
you now what in other words what what is
embedded in that process shot
even more fully embedded in in melees
the French directors films like trip to
the moon where he explicitly goes into a
realm of fantasy is not only that the
film is the most profoundly realistic
medium that was ever invented it may
also be the most the the the most
expressive medium for the for the
rendering of non realistic states of
dream of nightmare of fantasy exactly
because of the freedom that that the
film medium allows and it even these
implications are at least embedded in
the use of the processed shots in
Porter's the Great Train Robbery the the
other short that you're going to see
tonight that is not by keaton is called
the lonedale operator it's it's a it was
made in 1911
and it in a way it's the most it's the
most advanced film of its time and
that's one reason and I what I hope when
you look at it you'll you'll watch
especially for how much more complex it
is then let's say the Great Train
Robbery now be a kind of small measure
of this Fred OTT principle that I've
been talking about let me mention a
couple of things about the lonedale
operator between 1907 and 1908 films
consisted of no more than twenty four
separate shots right between 1908 and
1913 led by DW Griffith and his company
the Biograph company many more shots
were introduced into the into a single
reel of film and in the lonedale
operator there are 98 shots six
intertitles one main title and two
written inserts all within a 17 minute
lane now think of that just the advent
of the access of complexity that has
occurred just in less than 10 years
right it's such a complicated film that
one of the things we realize even
looking at it if we look closely is that
it actually required a kind of
attentiveness that earlier films did not
as filmmakers began to make these things
and begin to make them longer and began
to make them more complicated they
realized that they couldn't just bring
the camera out and start shooting they
began to develop the formal
rationalizing strategies that led to the
making of movies as we understand them
there was a four day
shooting schedule created for the
lonedale operator it was one of the
first films to to to have this format
and of course it's the format that is
followed today with virtually every film
in different in different aspects and
this also required a pre-planned
shooting script they have to they had to
plan what they would pre plan all of
their shooting all of their shots all of
their camera angles they needed a
shooting script a written script films
didn't have written scripts at first but
lonedale did and it also required in
order for them to make their schedule
out of order shooting that is to say
they had to shoot certain things not in
the sequential order of that's one of
the most basic principles of filmmaking
because once you set up the camera for
for a shot of a particular environment
if that environment shows up later in
the film it's unbelievably more
expensive and time-consuming to
reconstitute that whole set so they
debate almost all films to this very day
are still shot out of sequence in order
to maximize the the the the the the time
you have nor in order to work at your
most efficient it was it's not an
efficient way to make a movie to shoot
it sequentially to follow the to follow
the script in its chronological sequence
and the lonedale operator is one of the
is maybe the first film to have all of
these features that we would associate
with with with a Mart with a modern or a
contemporary film you might notice in
the it's a it's an immensely complex
film even in terms of its content and I
might leave that I won't talk about that
much now except to say this watch the
way in which the film tries to deal with
what we might call hierarchies of gender
I mean the film is partly about how a
woman takes on a man's job you know I
guess it's her father her father is ill
and she has to take over running the the
train station she runs in and and so
there's a certain sense in which one of
the things that's dramatized socially is
it is a woman sort of moving into a kind
of masculine realm taking on a role
that's more aggressive than is
appropriate for the for the gender
ideologies that are dominant at the end
of the 19th century in the
it states but the film is pretty clever
about this like many such popular texts
because although it does grant this
woman a certain kind of masculine
Authority and competence it also has
other things in the film that balanced
that that remind us that she is still
nonetheless a weak vessel that she is
still a damsel in distress like the
typical Victorian construction of women
and was what you could see is that the
movie exhibits an anxiety about gender
roles that's also an anxiety that's
resident in the society itself and I
won't talk more about this now it's
something but we will develop this
aspect of the movies the movies as a
reflection of social anxieties and
social and social problems as the as the
course goes on but I do want to call
your attention to certain technical
things that you can watch to at least
one technical item in the film well it
contains what might be called rhyming
scenes in which at one point in the film
you'll see a sequence of scenes in
particular shot and then later in the
film almost exactly the same shot will
reappear and the effect of this of
course is to create a sense of coherence
and a sense of familiarity in the
audience it's actually a very subtle and
careful strategy that Griffith himself
devised it creates a kind of continuity
and clarity to the whole film watch for
example how the doorway to the lonedale
station is photographed when you first
see it how this image anchors the film's
spatial relationships and how the film
has a certain trajectory of movement
that is repeated as the film goes on so
that for example early in the film we
see the heroine go from the exterior to
the interior of the ticket office and
then to the inner office of the
telegraph operator and we see her do
this right and then this sets up a kind
of basic location and basic action for
the entire film it's as if what happens
in that moment sits up creates a
familiarity with the for the audience
with that sort of geography of the movie
because a lot of the action and will
depend on our understanding of that
geography and then there are at least
four different times that Griffith
repeats that basic three shot reject
arei from the exterior to the interior
of the ticket office and thence from the
inner up to the inner office
of the telegraph operator it happens
four times in the film so it so the film
has a kind of visual coherence by the
time you come to it the third or fourth
time it's as if you're intimate with the
physical geography of the movie this is
actually a structural feature that it's
easy to miss it but it's it's actually
very artful and we can see it's a it's a
mark of how far film has come even by
1911 that this level of attentiveness is
is available to us in the film there's
much more that could be said about the
lonedale operator but I will leave it to
your intelligence and your attentiveness
to try to pick out more thing and again
we're only talking about a 17-minute
a 17-minute film well buster Keaton's
career could be said in some degree to
enact in small the larger processes I've
been describing he comes into film late
and in fact if we were working perfectly
chronologically in terms of when Chaplin
became a director he would precede key
but I've organized the film according to
the feature the dates of the feature
films and the general is an earl a
decade earlier than modern times which
is the last quote silent film it's not
really a silent film but it's the last
silent film in a deep sense that was
ever made it was made in the sound era
in 1936 and when we next week will talk
more about the implications of that and
why that was a very daring thing for
Chaplin to do something like almost a
decade after the advent of sound he made
a movie that essentially had no dialogue
in it so Keaton came a little later it
comes into moviemaking after a little a
few years after Chaplin but his but his
career has a similar trajectory he began
his career in legitimate theater in
vaudeville and anden and in on the
performance circuit and and was an
acrobat from a very young age from the
age of two or three was in his parents
stage act he was actually mandala of his
acrobatic feats on his parents stage act
one very famous passage in his his
father used to take him he was just a
young kid three or four years old five
years old we take him by this legs and
swing him back and forth like this
he had very long hair and he would sweep
the floor with his hair
and then swing him two or three times
this would happen live he would swing
him like this and let him go and the kid
five years old would fly against the
wall and fall down it would look
terrible and Keaton took later in his
life Keaton talked about this there were
actually some cities in which the the
societies for the port for the
Prevention of Cruelty to Children came
in and shut down the shut down the act
wouldn't allow the act to go on not
stupid cuz his father was a drunkard and
sometimes perform drunk and Keaton was
sometimes injured he was also injured
when he made his own movies for because
he was such a daring Acrobat and Keaton
recounts that when he first began to
perform in this he would make faces you
know faces that indicated pain or
happiness or relief when his father was
manipulating him this way but he found
that the audience responded much more
comically much more immediately if he
just kept his face expressionless and
that's where they're developed the
probably mistaken label for Keaton of
the great stone face and in his films
very often you'll see this young man
facing monumental catastrophe his face
will look out at things without ever
changing expression there is something
kind of kind of comical about that
you'll see some examples of this in the
in the general well you'll you'll see in
the two short films that Keaton began to
make that he enters film at already a
relatively sophisticated time and yeah
and the shorts I'm asking you to look at
are very interesting remarkable films in
in their own way and what one of the
things they teach us and one of the
reasons I want you to look closely at
Keaton is they T as they show us yet
again another aspect of what I mean when
I talk about the Fred OTT principle this
development of evolution and and and and
and increasing and increasing complexity
because if you look at cops or if you
look at one week what you will see
Keaton doing in those films is learning
how to link jokes together in some sort
of a coherent way but the films and and
there are wonderful coherent sequences
in these films but still one doesn't
feel that there's a real character in
them that there's a sustained coherent
fictional universe being dramatized
being cops one does feel this there's
much more sort of textural coherence in
cops but what we can see Canton doing is
beginning to move from the idea of a
single joke to a sequence of jokes and
then by the time we get to the general
moving from a sequence of from a single
joke to a sequence of jokes to a
sustained narrative which incorporates
within it various kinds of comical jokes
and also sequence jokes because Keaton's
best jokes are not single jokes at all
not one liners but the joke will be told
again and again or what or really what
will happen is he will do something
you'll think how could and then the next
step will top what he's done before and
the next step will top you think that he
got to a point where would be impossible
to an another comic complication to what
he's done when he of course does it and
this becomes one of the deep principles
of Chaplin of Keaton's comedy there are
numerous examples of it in both the two
shorts and in this in the longer film
that I that the the general but let me
mention an example from the general very
early in the general there's a sequence
it's probably the quintessential Keaton
sequence and I won't go into such detail
as to spoil the film for you but let me
just say it involves a cannon and it
involves Keaton who's chasing after
Keaton plays a the engineer of a
locomotive a locomotive engineer and the
general of the title is not a Mart a
military general it's a locomotive the
locomotive is called the general and the
stand the film recounts a historically
true story of a time when the Union Army
he meant that what the Confederate Army
the Union Army came into Confederate
territory and stole a locomotive
belonging to the Confederacy and missed
and and he would and Keaton in a comic
vein retells retells this this story
when you watch this cannon sequence
you'll see exactly what I mean you're
and this sequence is at the heart of
James ag's essay on the silent film
comedy and when you read that essay
you'll see even more clearly what I mean
by a trajectory joke or a sequence joke
which builds and builds and builds and
keep stopping itself well this cannon
sequence is a perfect example of that
and it's a perfect example of it not
only because we see the joke getting
more complicated
as it goes on but as the joke becomes
more complicated something else happens
the joke becomes more than a joke it
becomes a kind of comment on experience
it becomes a kind of comment on on on on
on what life is like that is to say we
move from something that simply makes a
smile to something that makes us think
about the world that comments on the
world that imagines the world in a
coherent way I'll try to be more
explicit about this in a in a moment
so in Keaton's career we see him doing
astonishing things as an acrobat and we
would admire him just for his acrobatic
performances in these films watching
this film in the in the general for
example the way in which when he's
piloting his locomotive chasing the
people who have stolen his original
locomotive how he's the only one on the
train and he crawls all over the Train
he could go almost every while the train
is running he'll crawl up to the front
of it he'll run to the back of it to put
more fuel in yeah you what you can what
you can see is in and and also you can
see this stuff happening in really
happening it's not fake in any way
because there's a there is a camera
following the train as it's moving you
can see it's really moving because you
can you can see it you can see it moving
on the track and you can see the world
behind it and you can you can tell the
Keaton is not faking these effects well
this cannon sequence is a is a is a
sublimely rich example of this complex
process I've been describing and it has
to do in part with what I call the
multiplicity principle which I will
define in a moment so we see Keaton as
an actor as an acrobat as an acrobat
actor as an incredibly in as a man much
more than Chaplin interested in the
technology of motion pictures and of
cinema and you'll see a couple of
examples in the films you're going to
look at tonight in which we see Keaton
exploring in a somewhat systematic way
the nature of the illusion of the motion
pictures there's one remarkable moment
comical moment in one week in which the
heroine gets into a bathtub and it looks
like you and she's sitting in the
bathtub she's starting to get up and
looks like you're actually about to see
some unmentionable parts of her body and
just as that's about to happen a hand
comes in front of the camera and blocks
you and it's actually a very disturbing
moment in a way because it interrupts
narrative flow it's a it's a it's an
intervention from the outside whose hand
it is it's not a character in the film
it's the director so right it's very
bold moment because what it does is it
reminds you of the film as an artifact
it reminds you that the film is an
artifice in other words it's a moment of
self-reflexiveness or self-consciousness
that you would never see in a Chaplin
film but shows he Keaton's astonishing
interest in the technology of motion
pictures I had many examples that Gregg
and I had ready but I don't have time to
show them to you maybe you can put up
while I'm talking the The Playhouse
one of his most famous examples of this
is a film called the playoffs in which
he ends up playing every role in the
movie and the way he did this was
incredible it was incredibly interesting
he would shoot the film and then he
would shoot the film but he would but he
put he put masking tape over the lens of
the camera and only one little tiny part
of the of the lens of the camera was was
what would expose the film and he would
he would shoot that then he would rewind
the film and then if he were over in
this corner for that shot then he'd move
over and sit in the other corner and put
a new kind of tape on the camera filming
again and the film you're going to see
will show this and you can see they're
all busted it's a it's an it's a it's
again what it shows us he's a technician
he's interested in the technology of
motion pick of the of the motion picture
camera and what kinds of manipulations
are possible because he's the conductor
right he's you know as it turns out he's
going to also end up being the only
person in the audience well and then
finally what what I've already implied
is that Keaton's jokes and his technical
interests also end up making him a
metaphysician a philosopher an artist
now Keaton himself could never
articulate his own ambitions in this way
if you said mr. Keaton your vision of
the absurd universe is more complex and
rich than jean-paul Sartre as in fact it
is incidentally he would laugh he
wouldn't even understand what you were
talking about not only because he'd
never read Sartre since he died before
he was most sorry he was alive when
search was alive actually but but he
undoubtedly he did not read but the
universe that he projects has has a kind
of content or a meaning that's a
function of how intelligent he is about
exploiting his medium and telling his
stories as if
his jokes Express a vision of life a
sense of experience now this so you and
of course this is what you're looking at
is sort of minor Keaton here but it's
you but it shows his it shows his
technical his technical interests well
so what I'm it was so let me explain
what I mean basically by the
multiplicity principle this process of
accretion and complexity I've described
and a certain point you get to a point
where what began as a gag or as a mere
entertainment takes on a density or a
texture that makes you think wait a
second
the vision of experience that's
projected in this text is intrinsically
interesting that is to say there's an
understanding of life that's embedded in
the story when you reach the point where
the text itself embodies some sort of
understanding of life and it's coherent
an understanding of life that's
coherently presented powerfully
presented what you're what you're
looking at is what I call art you might
just call it more intelligent
entertainment but this is a way of
distinguishing between entertainment and
art and which there's a certain point at
which entertainment becomes so
complicated that it's more than mere
entertainment when does that occur well
one way to tell when it occurs is to
watch for what I call the multiplicity
principle when events in the film play
more than one function do more than one
job when they forward the story but also
declare for character when they express
when they make you laugh but also
Express a vision of life and at the same
time X are consistent with the character
psychological nature that multiplicity
that density that texture is what we
associate with works of art right a bad
example would be you're all familiar I
hope with the kind of bad soap opera
line in which a character comes in and
says something like this oh hello John
my long-lost brother who just got out of
the insane asylum after 15 years of
unfair misery right what's wrong with
that line why is that a stupid line
although we hear them all the time what
what's wrong with it is very awkward
exposition but why is it so awkward what
makes it so awkward it's it's its
intention is clear it wants to present
information to the audience but in order
to do that what what is it violated
seems to be something that follows the
edge of the carrot to be something that
is that honors the characters nature
exactly right that's a very good answer
what's your name
Michael thank Michael that's very good
and listen what happened okay I want to
give information to the audience in
order to do that I'll compromise the
characters basic nature because no
brother no sister talking to her brother
would recount the brothers history to
the brother right that just wouldn't
happen right so in order to accomplish
one task the text has compromised itself
on another test but imagine a story in
which this information emerges Indre in
dramatic ways two characters are talking
and mary says to Joan Oh Joan my
brother's coming back from the asylum
and she says really I didn't even know
he was in the asylum and Mary pulls back
and says I don't know if I should tell
you right okay so we have a we have a
dramatic scene in which what in which
the information that the audience is
supposed to have is presented in a way
that maybe tells us something about
Mary's nature and maybe tells us
something about Joan's nature that is
multiplicity right more well that's what
I mean by the multiplicity principle you
will see many many instances of one of
what I'm calling the multiplicity
principle in Catonsville especially see
it in these astonishing repeated
sequences in which we see in which we
see that and I'm talking now in a way
about the general in which we see the
Keaton hero who sort of is steadfast but
also a muddler he keeps he keeps doing
the same things they're not really
likely to help him and then he gets help
from the outside and what the what
Keaton's jokes repeatedly depend upon
the idea of of accident in a certain way
and I'll come back to that in a finally
in a second so so think about the
multiplicity principle the difference
between entertainment and art again this
is a principle I'll come back to and try
to illustrate with greater concreteness
and greater leisure in later lectures
but I want you to be aware of these of
these issues so the general can be
understood as a kind of culminating text
in at least two ways it's a culmination
of Keaton's career that is to say the
jokes and gags that are enacted in in
the film recall many earlier Keaton
films and the
basic character of the general is the
basic character of the Keaton hero a
steadfast unremarkable young man who
persevere 'he's in the face of
catastrophic difficulties with mostly
comic expectations on very small
expectations of success who often
muddles through almost despite himself
right now but it isn't merely but I say
almost despite himself and this is where
the complexity of Keaton's vision of
life comes in why I'm saying that Keaton
moves from being merely a jokester or
being merely a great entertainer to
being an artist his jokes and body an
idea of what experience is like and it's
a very powerful mordant mature idea of
experience because what happens again
and again in the small jokes the
sequence jokes and Keaton's work
especially in the general and in the
larger film what happens again and again
is a is a an adventure in which a
steadfast relentless young hero does
everything he can to to accomplish his
goal and it's obvious that he's up
against forces far beyond himself that
he could never that there's a big
unbelievable Mis mismatch between this
meniscal tiny figure and the and his
powers and the forces he's art he's
fighting against this one Keaton film
called the navigator in which the Keaton
character even more than with the
locomotive in the general has to
navigate an ocean liner and he's alone
on the ocean liner and you see him
running up and down into the engine room
back up to this up to the bridge not
running all over the ocean liner in
great difficulties there's a wonderful
film late film made in 1928 just his
last silent film called steamboat bill
jr. in which he dramatizes an
astonishing song and an astonishing and
astonishing hurricane a long extended
sequence in which we see him trying to
escape the hurricane trying to contend
against this natural force that's so
gigantic so that so the general is a
culmination in the sense that it gives
us another version and the richest the
richest version so far of the of the
adventures of this kind of Keaton hero
but what makes it or what makes it sort
of metaphysical or philosophically
interesting is that what what this joke
repeatedly does and what the structure
the whole film repeatedly says it's
something like this we get through we
make it through life not mostly it's a
it's a great comic Morton comics we get
through life mostly not because of
anything we've done but because of
accident we live in a contingent
universe right the idea of contingency
is at the heart of what of Keaton's
jokes we could we could call them jokes
about contingency the word contingent is
interesting remember it means both live
it means libel but not certain but not
certain to occur it means possible right
so so for its deep it means dependent
upon subject to condition by right in
law you could say something you can say
that something that is contingent is
dependent for its effect on something
that may or may not occur as in a
contingent estate or legacy right in
logic the same thing dependent upon some
condition or upon the truth of something
else not true a priori not necessary so
what Keaton's jokes constantly do is
they show us two things they show us a
world in which human agency matters
because if this men drew didn't keep
that's a Jewish word for schlemazel is
it clown if this Schmendrick did not
if this Schmendrick did not keep on so
steadfastly he wouldn't survive but his
keeping on so steadfastly still wouldn't
make him survive if there weren't the
intervention of mere accident stuff he
has no control over there's one
magnificent moment in the in in one week
for example where he's standing in a
certain place and the house and the
house behind him falls down and he's
happens just by accident to be standing
so that by the open window in the house
fall so he doesn't get hurt he used this
joke more than once in other films
because such a great one but it's a
perfect example of what I mean a partial
example of what I mean because he's not
responsible for the fact that he escaped
on the other hand because he was trying
to get away from difficulties maybe he
was in that particular position because
of acts of his own so so what it says of
what so what this joking vision says
about the world is something that's true
we all love the idea that we've gotten
to where we are by our own acts by our
own conscious control the truth of the
matter is that life but life is much
more
agent than that it's partly accident
it's partly luck and something deeper
than that Kaitlyn's vision of the
universe is one which suggests that
while the universe may screw you up
sometimes it won't always do that that
is to say it's not the universe in
Keaton's world is not angry at us it's
indifferent to us it doesn't give a damn
about us it's not aware of us it's too
big for us right you can't come away
from Keaton's films without a
simultaneous sense of the importance of
human action of human agency but also of
the inadequacy of human agency of how
contingent every experience every
adventure every personality is and that
and that meaning that idea of the world
is a profound one I think it tells it so
that so that even though Keaton is
telling a joke embedded in the joke is a
kind of interpretation of life and
embedded in the film is the kind of
interpretation of life when you are
looking at the general I think you will
see multiple examples of this kind of
thing let me say one last thing I
haven't mentioned anything about the
structure of the film I'm a little out
of order
watch how the film is structured it's a
very it's a much more complex variation
on what I said about lonedale operator
the film begins with him going up the
track and then the second half of the
film has him going back down the track
you may not be aware of it but actually
the film in a certain sense has its tail
in its mouth when it goes up the track
he has a series of adventures when he
comes back down he has a series of
adventures that in a certain sense
replicate what's happened before the
film mirrors itself in a way repeats
itself watch it's an incredibly elegant
structure this Incred and and the
elegance of the structure reminds us
also of the in its own way also reminds
us of this principle of contingency
that's at the heart of Keaton's vision
of the world let me conclude by
reminding you again of what I said
earlier when I call Keaton a philosopher
and a metaphysician
and a wise person about the world I do
not at all mean to suggest that if you
were asked Keaton to explain how he
thought about the world he could do this
that's that's the job of professors and
literary and film critics right what I'm
saying to you is that Keaton like many
great artists had an intuitive
understanding of the world which he
press with greater and greater
complexity in the medium of the cinema
and in the general we have what is
ultimately a culminating instance of
that one last point about the film as a
culminating example it's not just a
culmination of Keaton's career it's a
culmination of silent film in it as a
whole
Keaton would have expected his audience
to recognize the degree to which this
film was a parody or a mockery of famous
historical films made by DW Griffith it
puts down the pretentiousness and the
martial valour that's celebrated in so
many of the historical spectacles that
Griffith and other serious directors
were making at the time and it and it
also goes back in a certain way to the
very roots of film what was the very
first narrative film or one of the very
first that also a film about a train
robbery right called the Great Train
Robbery well this is about a train
robbery - and who is the central
character in this one really a train is
the central object the central more more
interesting in some ways than the
character himself and there are many
other ways in which the particular
features of the general allude to and in
some sense summarize the history of
silent film and all of the original
audience coming to see the general would
have been of course alert to these
connections would have been literate in
these connections wouldn't have needed
footnotes or professors to tell him
about it because they would have lived
through the history they would have
lived through the history of the
previous 20 years they would have seen
other Keaton films they would have seen
DW Griffith they would have the history
of the of the medium of movies in their
heads when they sat down to watch the
general so that's another way in which
the general is a profoundly culminating
text
you